[Music] l'
étranger
est
deux semaines après que nous ayons été enfermés pour la première fois,
nous avons vraiment réalisé combien de temps cela
allait prendre,
nous avons commencé à faire des cours de zoom, la
société a en fait donné un morceau de marley
au sol à chaque danseur qui était en
ville
et ils ont installé soit  le dos d'un
tabouret ou d'un comptoir
pour un bar afin qu'ils puissent faire leur
propre bar sur environ deux mètres sur deux mètres
mais sans avoir
accès à un studio, il est vraiment difficile
d'atteindre ce
niveau de conditionnement prêt pour la scène
physique
[Musique]
centre
euh
je pense que la principale lutte pour l'équipe de santé
et de bien-être était simplement de garder
nos danseurs positifs
en étant isolés
[Musique]
nouveau
vous étranger